winner et des soldats syriens il répète
toujours les mêmes salades c'est pas
parce que tu es premier ministre que tu
peux te permettent de déformer la
réalité
quelqu'un dans ce bâtiment a trahi son
gouvernement et sa patrie
[Musique]
s'il s'avère que vous avez caché des
informations vous serez poursuivis pour
atteinte à la loi sur le secret d'état
catherine gun qui a pu d'après vous
révéler le mail de cause à quelque chose
que tu dois voir d'affilée ça une me
fais gaffe si le mémo est vrai la voix
sur toi peut envoyer en prison
vous êtes une espionne vous travaillez
pour le gouvernement britannique
non moi je travaille pour les
britanniques je ne recueille pas des
données électroniques pour que l'état
monte au prix tech
saignements sont peut-être manipuler
pour que l'angleterre entre en dire
c'est journal doit arrêter de prendre ce
que dit blair pour argent comptant
vous n'aviez rien à gagner et tout à
perdre c'est passible d'une peine de
prison
voulez vous prendre ce risque cette
guerre est historiquement impopulaire
savuth partout dans le monde entier
la plus grande manif de l'histoire de
l'humanité si on ne rend pas ça public
ça reviendrait à dire que personne n'a
le droit de prévenir les britanniques
quand leur gouvernement lormand
[Musique]
ce que vous avez fait est extraordinaire
cette guerre
est illégal
le public a le droit de savoir pourquoi
mon mobile
était d'empêcher une guerre et sauver
des vies je te tiens la vérité